hi
so a few weeks ago we were filming uh
the show and i met two sisters in the
audience who said
that they weren't fans of christmas
music and it led to a conversation i was
not anticipating take a look
clap of hands who's not a fan of
christmas music and finds it triggering
there you go
may i ask why
you spoke up for that 23 percent
um well we were really poor growing up
so we never really had christmases
so it was kind of a hard story for us so
it's gotten better as we've gotten older
and as we have kids now this is the only
holiday i actually decorate now for
to try to make it better for my kids huh
we're sisters and as we're growing up i
had to take care of my brothers and
sisters a lot
and um
one of our connections was you
we always had a little bit of a tough
time between each other and then um
she was going to college in madison
and i went out to visit her and we went
and saw charlie's angels
and that was our connection we just flew
in last night and we'll be leaving
tomorrow because we just came to see you
yeah that's right come on
ornaments were something i started
collecting when my daughters were born
and i'm very territorial about those
ornaments and i don't know maybe we can
like start collecting some ornaments or
do something together something to like
hang on your trees would you guys ever
consider coming back here and doing
something else for the show in honor of
christmas together
[Applause]
[Music]
oh please don't bother don't even worry
about it
i'm
so excited to be doing this with you and
i just love that like when you
try to make something possible or you
think maybe something
good could come out of something and
then it does it's just it's so hopeful
and you know we were just sitting at the
news desk with brook shield and i asked
you that question and you just came out
with your truth do you think
that that was a relief to you and anyone
else who might have heard your story
well
honestly it's
it's all just it all just came to me i
i'm not really um
a sharer yeah she is not i i don't
normally cry yeah i actually i don't
know what it is about this venue but
you're sharing and crying like every
time we're together which i'm loving i
said i i honestly feel like there was a
connection with you like where i could
honestly feel open and honest to you yes
yes oh i'm so glad i thought when we met
after i heard your story and then at the
end of the show invited you up on the
stage and just said you know okay we
have a connection with ornaments and i
just thought
let's have it wrapped up in an ornament
but this is our chance to create new
memories
new feelings
and the christmas we start now and
looking forward how do you feel about
that sounds good to me cause i'm out to
change christmas for you
[Applause]
if we have a connection maybe we have
our own little christmas miracle between
us you know you manifested coming here i
zeroed in on you none of this happened
by accident oh it was meant to be
so from here on out can we be christmas
friends and make each other an ornament
every year and like build new
non-traditional traditions
yes anything you want okay great
so i'm gonna start
with these two
i'll start with those too there's a
little something inside
okay
no
yes
thank you oh my god
yes jessica
[Applause]
obviously spend it however you want just
a little christmas treat to kind of you
know get yourself some merry christmas
presents
um and um i'm very grateful to our house
who helped us um make this possible
because obviously there's each a 2500
gift certificate inside those beautiful
ornaments and
i
[Applause]
um okay so
they're
similar but a little different
and that'll be the first of a tradition
we start
in huge arena
beautiful
it's gorgeous i love it i'm really happy
i met you
we're happy to meet you
[Applause]
and i'm glad we found each other
[Music]
well nicole and jessica thank you so
much and um maybe we can make a date for
next christmas too yeah definitely yeah
i i never imagined
that like to to just be around you
you are everything that anybody could
think of as far as greatness and
kindness and light
i mean i always remember that day when
i uh
saw pop up on instagram or youtube
and it was like tickets to drew
barrymore show and i was like and i
turned and i looked at my husband and i
said and i don't do this i said i'm
going to new york and i'm going to meet
drew barrymore
and
i texted my sister and i was like
would you go
and
boom here we are and i mean never did i
imagine never did i ever
[Applause]
thank you nicole and jessica we'll be
right back
[Music]
you